The town on the island of
Cyprus also looks like
Sludge City. And indeed,
the authorities here have
been taken to court over
failings in its waste
management.
The state of the Cyprus
sewage system leaves a
lot to be desired.
So maybe what we're
seeing in this image is a
catastrophic sewage
leak.
Turkey permanently
quarantines the ghost
town to be used as a
kind of bargaining chip
in negotiations over the
island's future.
It forces the residents
to rebuild their lives
elsewhere. They were
basically told that they
can.
Never return on the
threat of being shot.
Varosha becomes a time
capsule.
The place sits abandoned
like a movie set.
You might pass a shop
with fashions from 1974
car dealerships where
you can see automobiles
still inside an airport
with aircraft still
parked on the runway
from 1974.